a spirit airlines flight from las vegas
bound for pittsburgh had to turn around
just seconds before takeoff passengers
say they had to hold on tight as the
pilot slammed the brakes 8 news now
reporter victoria saha on this story
victoria
spirit flight 334 was supposed to take
off last night but right before takeoff
the faa says the pilots realized there
was something wrong with the air speed
indicator which made them push the
brakes
jennifer allen was on board with her
service dog on spirit flight 334 she
thought her tuesday night flight was
taking off like usual when they slammed
on the brakes obviously knew something
was very wrong you can see here from
flight radar 24 the flight was ready to
take off then stopped we were
full speed i mean seconds from lifting
off i actually thought we had
even begun to lift off spear airlines
released a statement saying the crew
decided to not take off due to a
potential maintenance issue the plane
braked safely upon taxing to the gate
the aircraft experienced a flat tire
we were sitting there on the runway we
heard a loud boom
and
the plane shifted weight
and we could see some sort of steam or
smoke out the window
the fire truck fire truck had come out
to the plane allen says the ordeal
continued passengers were left waiting
for hours after being promised a new
plane but it never came
she says it was it wasn't until 2 a.m
that she received a meal and a hotel
voucher the 9 40 p.m flight from last
night took off this morning close to 10
a.m reporting live from the newsroom
vitoria saha 8 news now